hey bro let's have a look at question
five question five now some of you
who've been going to care of it
others of you start with a little bit so
let's have a look it to get up now I'll
admit it looks like it makes the problem
of what was because that denominator is
now a cubic right and you think you know
usually when you go from quadratic
security it does make things rheumatica
us we remember when I showed you the
cubic formula and you looked at it in
your like yeah not cool okay but this is
one of those beautiful times we're going
for a quadratic to a cubic denominator
actually does not increase the
complexity problem at all literally at
all watch what happens I want to say
it's equivalent to some other set of
partial fractions right what would the
partial fractions be number four if you
just had two linear factors down there
there's two k20 you've got two fractions
they're problem okay but I have three
factors so I'm gonna get three partial
fractions
now believe it or not this is just as
easy to split as before it doesn't look
like it because when you add the
right-hand side together to put them
into one gigantic fraction you look like
you get something worse off I know I'm
gonna have to beat this because you put
it all together this is gonna have an X
plus 2 and X minus 3 and you're like you
roast quadratic okay you do the same
with B it's gonna have X plus 1 X minus
3
the other two denominators and then you
do it with C which you'll have X plus 1
X plus 2 now I could write the whole
denominator on the bottom but it's gonna
be the same to the left-hand side so I'm
just going to sort of skip a step you
guys see what's gonna happen I'm just
gonna write the numerators and there's
my equivalent statement okay in fact
this is exactly a quadratic identity
you've dealt with these before except
it's in a nicely form that will give it
to you easily let's try this you pick a
value of X you pick one that's
convenient for you right for instance
you might pick x equals negative 2 now
what will happen okay well that's just a
bad at the left-hand side first that's
going to be 4 plus 38 minus paid to yeah
Shh what happens on the right hand side
what disappears this disappears cuz that
negative to make sense here oh it's gone
right but that's not the only thing that
disappears right this guy disappears too
because it hasn't exposed to as well
right so that's going to be zero all
you're left with is this middle guy it's
being x now it's negative two right so
this would become negative 1 this would
become negative 5 so you just get 5
right what's that on left-hand side 4
plus 38 is 42 minus 32 is 10 5 dr. ho
right so even though it looks like it's
an order of magnitude worse the problem
ends up being exactly the same you can
repeat it to get a MC okay do you need
me to finish it or anything you can get
it from there that's all right